they say they have no hope of Ever
Getting Justice for their loved ones in
their Homeland so they've come to the
Philippines five members of myanmar's
chin ethnic group are suing their
country's leader General mingang and
eight military commanders for war
crimes says his nephew chakum was
murdered by Myanmar soldiers while on
his way to help put out a fire according
to eyewitness they shot him two times at
his chest and they cut of his finger
took off his wedding ring and stolen his
watch and cell phone Myanmar has been in
a state of Civil War since the military
seized power in 2021 from the
democratically elected government of
Onan sui the complainants say their
relatives are just some of hundreds
killed in predominantly Christian chin
State an entire Villages have been
burned an international humanitarian law
in the Philippines allows for the
prosecution of war crimes perpetrated
elsewhere it would be a landmark case
should the Philippines Department of
Justice decide to move forward with a
trial especially since there are
allegations of human rights violations
here as well that have not been
investigated the Philippines has no
intention of rejoining the IC president
Ferdinand Marcus Jr has refused to
cooperate with the international
criminal court as it seeks to
investigate possible crimes during
former president Rodrigo detes
anti-narcotics campaign if at this point
a state is not willing at some point it
may
actually seize the moment and say that
we're going to prosecute this and this
is uh precisely a case uh that we think
uh the president can use to prove that
the Philippines is in fact willing un
aable to prosecute atrocity
crimes no matter what the outcome is
lean says the fact that they're able to
make a step towards bringing myanmar's
military Hunter to justice is in itself
an achievement barnab Al jazer
Manila make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer